tony saint-léger bonsoir alors que les
bombardements
des bombardements sont en cours on l'a
vu tout à l'heure dans ce reportage de
nos confrères de france 2 dans l'est de
l'ukraine des publications ont fait état
ces derniers jours de susi ville
ukrainien prêt à se défendre en cas
d'invasion russe oui effectivement une
des publications c'est celle ci regardez
cette photo publiée sur twitter le 12
février une femme assise dans un bus
téléphone portable dans une main et un
fusil d'assaut dans l'autre en tout des
contrats des contractions devant des
passagers semble-t-il
impassible et qui nous peut-être même
pas remarqué la chose la légende de ce
tweet elle lui dit quoi elle nous dit en
anglais voici la vie en ukraine
actuellement leur contexte favorable
évidemment pour que la photo soit
crédible sauf qu'elle n'y a rien à voir
avec les circonstances qu'on lui prête
on va vous montrer comment évidemment
une première recherche d'image inversée
nous renvoie à 2020 puisque 2020 depuis
2020 cette photo elle régulièrement
utilisé comme un photomontage
humoristique l'image est censée montrer
comment les civils russes en
l'occurrence se défendent au quotidien
et on voit que le l'un des blogs est
l'une des légendes à l'époque c'est même
une fille ou en biélorussie donc rien à
voir ni avec l'ukraine ni avec la russie
ce blog en avril 2020 il nous explique
comment justement cette photo est
devenue un mème et y mentionne je vous
le disais l'une des légendes la seconde
recherche d'image inversée elle nous est
faite par un moteur de recherche russe
yandex et il nous amène à des photos
d'un compte instagram le voici et on
retrouve effectivement sur ce compte des
photos d'une jeune femme très
ressemblante à celle de la publication
virale et on la voit d'ailleurs
régulièrement porter le même bonnet de
couleur beige alors s'agit-il de la même
personne eh bien oui et cette jeune
femme elle est russe elle vient de
novossibirsk novossibirsk en sibérie
elle est mannequin comédienne et elle
s'appelle ekaterina glady caiga dic
c'est justement le nom de son 2 m compte
instagram et c'est celui-ci qui nous
intéresse pourquoi parce qu'on va
retrouver la photo qui nous intéresse ce
soir c'est là l'origine de la photo
virale la voix si on est le 27 mars 2020
donc rien à voir avec l'actualité en ce
moment et la légende nous dit je vais au
stand de tir j'ai un ak-47 vos ennemis
le regretteront art commentaires légende
a volontairement provocant humoristique
et ironique tout ce qu'on veut à un
internaute qui lui pose la question de
savoir ce qu'il en est réellement sur le
réseau social virus veka est bien elle
explique qu'elle revenait simplement
d'une séance de photos je le disais les
comédienne mannequin que l'armé était
factice et que personne n'en sait et non
sur mes ému dans le bus doucette cette
légende sur son compte instagram alors
c'est peut-être étonnant mais ça n'a en
tout cas rien à voir avec la situation
actuelle en ukraine mary notre photo ac
virale là aussi il s'agit d'une image
décontextualisés mais c'est un grand
classique de la désinformation mais vous
allez le voir le rapprochement qui est
fait ce soir est assez n'est pas en tout
cas dénué de sens pas entièrement
regardez plutôt cette photo elle nous
montre quoi des hommes et des femmes à
genoux dans la neige qui se tiennent par
le bras qui semble prié une photo que
l'on retrouve dans plusieurs
publications dont celle ci publications
facebook qui cumule plus de 9600 partage
et le commentaire nous avions qu'il
s'agit de chrétiens ukrainien qui prit
en plein air dans la neige face à la
menace de guerre qui prévaut dans le
pays alors rapide une rapide recherche
d'image inversée nous permet de trouver
l'origine encore dû tricher en
l'occurrence c'est cet article qui date
du 25 octobre 2019 donc rien à voir avec
l'actualité ukrainienne de du en ce
moment article de 2019 tout comme la
photo et cette photo est bien on apprend
que ce sont en fait des missionnaires
protestants ukrainien qui prient
effectivement dans un parc de la ville
de kharkiv kharkiv c'est ce point rouge
on est toujours à l'est de l'ukraine
kharkiv donc que l'on voit ici sur cette
carte 7,7 ses prières ce sont en fait
des manifestations silencieuses pour
dénoncer des mouvements séparatistes pro
russes à donetsk est lougansk alors on
le rappelle de niet c'est ici louant ce
que c'est ici c'est évidemment à l'est
de l'ukraine et la journaliste de
préciser que je le dis on est en 2010 9
est bien certain que vous voyez sur la
photo font ça depuis cinq ans ça nous
ramène chaque jour ça nous ramène en
2014 la révolution ukrainienne la guerre
dans ton base et l'annexion de la crimée
alors la photo je le disais les
évidemment décontextualisés elle n'a
rien à voir avec les événements de 2022
mais évidemment les circonstances de
l'époque ne sont pas sans rappeler celle
d'aujourd'hui c'est justement cette
analogie qui explique que cette info que
ce que l'on peut voir sur les réseaux
sociaux est très crédible merci beaucoup
anthony et saint léger on peut retrouver
votre chronique sur notre site internet
www.francebillet.com dont on se retrouve
dans quelques instants le président
américain joe biden doit s'exprimer
d'une minute à l'autre sur cette crise
ukrainienne face aux craintes d'une
intervention russe et puis nous irons à
washington